في كثير من الأحيان عندما كان رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو يتحدث عن إيران ، كان
يتحدث إلى جمهور واحد
للرئيس دونالد ترامب
نتنياهو ربما كان أكثر
منتقدي الاتفاق النووي الإيراني
ودعمًا ودفع بشدة
لحملة الضغط القصوى التي يشنها ترامب
ضد إيران بفرض عقوبات  ضد
العديد من كبار المسؤولين الإيرانيين ، كان نتنياهو
يود كثيرًا أن يرى
ذلك مستمرًا ،
لكن الآن بعد أن أقر نتنياهو أخيرًا
أن جو بايدن هو
الرئيس المنتخب ، يبدو أنه يتحدث
إلى جمهور مختلف
من جمهور واحد بشكل مباشر وعلى ما يبدو
هنا للرئيس المنتخب  جو بايدن
في طرح ما هو في الأساس
قائمة أولويات نتنياهو أو ربما
قائمة
أمنياته من السياسة الخارجية لنا في المستقبل ،
يبقى نتنياهو ضد الاتفاق النووي الإيراني
ما لم يكن لديه
تغييرات كبيرة ترقيات مهمة
من منظور نتنياهو وهذه هي الرسالة التي يوجهها إلى الرئيس مباشرة-
انتخب جو
بايدن حتى قبل إدارة بيدن
في منتصف إلى أواخر يناير / كانون الثاني ،
ما يثير الاهتمام هنا
هو أنه لا يزال هناك نقاش مستمر
داخل مجتمع المخابرات الإسرائيلي
حول ما إذا كانت حملة الضغط الأقصى
وما إذا كان ترك
الاتفاق النووي الإيراني هو القرار الصحيح أم لا
، وذلك لأنه على الرغم من العقوبات
على الرغم من الخليج.  تنص
على زيادة الضغط على إيران والتحرك
نحو إسرائيل ، فإن
إيران تتحرك خارج نطاق
القيود
الموضوعة داخل JCPOA وفقًا
لتقرير الأسبوع الماضي من IIAA
إيران قد نقلت أجهزة طرد مركزي متطورة
إلى منشأة في ناتانز
وبدأت في تخصيب اليورانيوم
الزائد هناك  من
حدود الاتفاق النووي السابق ،
لكن هذا لن يغير
سياسة رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو وموقفه الذي كان
أن الصفقة النووية الإيرانية كانت
منذ البداية صفقة سيئة وسيواصل
الضغط ضدها وارن ليبرمان سي إن إن
القدس.